es ist buchstäblich fünf vor zwölf als
die eilmeldung nach draußen dringt um
kurz vor mitternacht twittert
eu-ratspräsident schallemission dass
sich die staats und regierungschefs in
sachen öl embargo doch noch geeinigt
haben maximaler druck auf russland um
den krieg zu beenden schreibt er und um
kurz vor eins spricht der stolz von
einer wichtigen botschaft an die ukraine
an russland und die menschen in der eu
die letzten stunden und tage gab es
spekulationen über das risiko eines
mangels an einigkeit in der aber es ist
wichtiger als je zuvor dass wir zeigen
dass wir in der lage sind stark und
standhaft zu sein
auch bundeskanzler olaf scholz twitter
zu später stunde von einschneidenden
sanktionen gegen russland es werde ein
embargo für einen großteil der
russischen öl importe geben konkret
heißt das russisches öl darf nicht mehr
per schiff in die eu importiert werden
das betrifft zwei drittel der russischen
öllieferungen weiter geöffnet bleibt
zunächst die druschba pipeline in orth
an beliefern auch deutschland und polen
mit russischem öl über die südlichen
röhren werden ungarn die slowakei und
tschechien versorgt ohne die pipeline
befürchtet vor allem ungarns
ministerpräsident viktor orban
erhebliche wirtschaftliche folgen für
sein land er hatte sich deswegen gegen
das öl embargo ausgesprochen
energie ist ein sehr ernstes thema das
ist kein kinderspiel es ist ernst das
heißt erst brauchen wir lösungen dann
die sanktionen verschont
nun kann ungarn das russische öl das
vollständig über die druschba pipeline
ins land fließt erst einmal weiter
beziehen doch wie lange genau und welche
zugeständnisse die eu noch an ungarn
gemacht hat dazu haben weder schauen
michelle noch kommissionspräsidentin
ursula von der leyen etwas gesagt ungarn
könne auf eine kroatische pipeline in
der adria umsteigen aber dafür brauche
es zeit und
es braucht einige investitionen und
objektiv müssen die raffinerien für das
binnenland ungarn modernisiert werden
weil das russische öl eine andere
qualität hat als das öl der adriatischen
pipeline
deutschland und polen wollen außerdem
bis zum jahresende komplett auf
russisches öl verzichten laut von der
leyen werden damit effektiv 90 prozent
von russlands ölexporten vom eu markt
abgeschnitten
für den eu gipfel scheint der beschluss
ein überraschender erfolg zu sein doch
es bleiben fragen wie zuverlässig der
kompromiss umgesetzt wird und ob die
sanktionen russlands präsident putin
tatsächlich so hart treffen wie erhofft
es bleiben also fragen nach dieser
kompromissfindung stellen wir sie
unserem korrespondenten florian hahn aus
brüssel zugeschaltet er das ganze für
uns verfolgt hat guten morgen das sei
maximaler druck auf russland das sagt
die eu kann dieser kompromiss
tatsächlich als erfolg verbucht werden
ich würde sagen dieser kompromiss hat
die europäische union gerade so vor
einer katastrophe bewahrt nicht
auszudenken was passiert wäre wie sehr
sich auch wladimir putin die hände
gerieben hätte wenn sich europa nichts
hätte einigen können jetzt also wacht
aber europa mit einem blauen auge auf
und einem ölembargo dem man dem zusatz
light verpassen müsste denn erstens das
war zwar schon vorher klar wenn man
sollte es noch mal festhalten dieses
embargo geht nicht von heute auf morgen
sondern erst für den großteil der eu ab
ende dieses jahres zweitens es gibt eben
diese großzügige ausnahme für ungarn
tschechien und die slowakei von der
nicht mal klar ist wie lange sie
eigentlich gelten soll und vor allem mit
welchen finanziellen entschädigungen
etwa man sie verkauft hat und drittens
diese art der verhandlungen ja ich würde
sagen der erpressung durch aber die wird
auch innerhalb der eu spuren
hinterlassen also es ist ein erfolg dass
europa sich gerade noch mal hat einigen
können aber maximaler druck auf russland
das sehe meines erachtens doch etwas
anders aus zumal dieser kompromiss jetzt
ja erst mal nur das russische öl
betrifft wie sieht es denn eigentlich
aus mit dem russischen gas
das ist der nächste entscheidende
punkt den man dabei achten muss in der
tat überweist europa weiterhin täglich
viele millionen euro nach russland in
die russische kriegskasse für russisches
gas über dieses thema ist also ein
mögliches importstopp ist gar nicht
diskutiert worden auf dem gipfel
zumindest gestern nicht denn weiterhin
ist die abhängigkeit allen voran von
deutschland von diesem russischen gas
dafür zu groß aber dass man sich damit
beschäftigen muss das zeigt eine andere
meldung denn heute stellt der russische
konzern gazprom die lieferung von gas in
die niederlande ein und zwar weil die
niederländer sich weigern dieses
russische gas in rubel zu bezahlen aber
so ist es innerhalb der eu auch
verabredet der niederländische
premierminister mark rutte hat dazu
heute nacht gesagt das sei für sein land
zu verkraften aber es zeigt eben dass
sich europa auch der rest europas auf
einen solchen importstopp dringend
vorbereiten muss anders gesagt dass hier
von gestern das war nur eine
zwischenstation
nach dem sechsten sanktionspaket das ist
unweigerlich also vor dem siebten
florian live aus brüssel vielen dank für
diese erklärung und einordnung